bon
à north vancouver au début du mois de
mars apparaissent les signes avant
coureurs d'une tragédie sur le point de
frapper le pays
on détecte all-in vers l'hypercentre la
première éclosion de lakovic 19 dans une
résidence pour personnes âgées au canada
dans un message chargée d'émotion la
médecin en chef de la province implore
la population de ne plus rendre visite
aux personnes âgées à une skin prix fort
tu t'es qu'une série dramatique à des
petits qui les définit un cadre une
grande joie pour moi je pense qu'il
était ému parce que ce sont des gens qui
sont très vénérable elle savait que
quand un virus comme ça et dans une
facilité comme ça il y avait il ya la
potentielle de beaucoup de transmissions
un des résidents infecté meurt le
lendemain le premier décès dû à la
cofidis d'infos canada des employés du
centre refuse de se présenter au travail
la situation vire au chaos
le docteur laisser chesnais dépêchés sur
place pour s'adresser aux membres du
personnel y avait des grands problèmes
dans l'ain dans le début de l'éclosion
avec les personnels parce que les gens
ont eu très peur il voulait pas
travailler là on a dû augmenter les
salaires pour qu'il continue à
travailler là
dans les chs ld du québec les éclosions
sur la côte ouest semble bien lointaine
selon un préposé aux bénéficiaires de la
région de montréal qui s'est confié à
nous sous le couvert de l'anonymat car
il n'a pas l'autorisation de parler aux
médias
on en parlait en outre orange les gens
croyaient plus pour freiner le virus il
faut agir vite
le 14 mars le gouvernement legault
déclare l'état d'urgence sanitaire est
visé aux résidents des centres
d'hébergement de longue durée sont
proscrites fia de ce2 de déconvenue ne
fait plus de prix de prévention jusqu'à
présent qu'à peu près n'importe où ou
d'un nom les autorités québécoises
espère avoir mis les aînés de la
province à la baie du virus
selon jose nord ce qu'il sait
mais cette stratégie n'arrive pas à
contenir le virus
quatre jours plus tard mario tremblay
une résidente d'une maison de retraite
de lavaltrie morts lakovic 19 se répand
comme une traînée de poudre dans
d'autres résidences
[Musique]
contrairement au québec en
colombie-britannique dès les première
éclosion les autorités effectuer un
dépistage systématique de tous les
résidents et employés des centres
infectés même ceux qui ne présentent pas
de symptômes
une analyse du milieu leur révèle que
les familles n'étaient pas le principal
mode de transmission
c'était plutôt les employés on a dit que
beaucoup de transmissions était dans la
salle des personnels ou aussi avec les
équipements qui était utilisée entre
patients comme les brassards
d'impression à triel del 21 mars
la régie régionale de la santé de
vancouver et mai une ordonnance
interdisant aux employés travaillé dans
plus d'un établissement du jour au
lendemain les gestionnaires des
résidences doivent se débrouiller
autrement
beaucoup de personnel travailler à
plusieurs établissements sait vraiment
comment le secteur fonctionne alors
c'était très problématique on hamm est
cette ordonnance en place mais on
pensait que c'était nécessaire pour
prévenir un cran
éclosion hassaka établissement à ce
moment là au québec à la fin du mois de
mars
aucune règle n'interdit le travail dans
plus d'un établissement notre préposé
lui travaille dans trois centres il se
retrouve sur la ligne de front sans
avoir accès à l'équipement de protection
nécessaire parce que j'avais vu ça comme
un logiciel mais pas tous riches ils
devaient pas que des gens creusent la
tête mais ma c'est pas souvent brûlés
une semaine plus tard il commence à
ressentir des symptômes légers et ça
c'est médiatement travailler mais il a
pu propager le virus avant que ses
symptômes n'apparaissent jeu le 3 avril
québec émet une consigne pour éviter
dans la mesure du possible que les
membres du personnel travaillent dans
plus d'un ch sld mais la pratique n'est
pas interdite
après cette période de quarantaine
notre préposé retournent au travail dans
plus d'un établissement
la seule façon pour lui de joindre les
deux bouts il a maintenant accès à un
équipement de protection adéquat mais en
raison du manque de personnel criant au
québec
il dit devoir parfois passer de la zone
chaude à la zone froide d'un même
établissement ont même si je suis
l'homme
ainsi je suis trop vite mon logis pages
qu'on n'y a pas un parchemin contenant
des classes qui sont trop vieux puis
comment les gens qui n'y est en cours je
m'entends tu en sors plus le problème
soit par courriel le ministère la santé
du québec dit qu'il arrive
exceptionnellement que nous soyons dans
l'obligation de déplacer des employés
d'un site à l'autre pour éviter la
rupture de service
la colombie britannique elle a instauré
un programme de compensation de 10
millions de dollars par mois pour les
employés touchés par leur donnant ce
limitant travail à un seul établissement
tous les travailleurs reçoivent un
salaire équitable une stabilité de l'air
afin qu'ils puissent travailler de ce
site sans difficulté financière n'est
interruption des soins aux patients la
côte ouest a évité le pire grâce au
dépistage systématique des résidences
touchées et des restrictions
draconiennes sur le mouvement personnel
une quarantaine d'établissements ont été
touchés alors qu'au québec c'est plus de
400 de province deux approches
différentes et des résultats aux
antipodes dans cette lutte contre un
ennemi commun
clavières